Kathy you said something beautiful about
how when writers get feedback from you
they feel safe with the notes that you
give them how can someone deliver a
message and maybe critique something but
do it in a safe way so that the people
can take it and change with it instead
of being wounded by it well I think
first of all you have to try and
understand and find out from the writer
what was your intent once you figure out
what their intent was you try to work
with that because you you want their
vision to shine through their
perspective of the situation that they
have put into their script their
perspective of what the main character
is who he is or who she is and what
they're about you want to make sure you
don't lose that and so that's why when I
give my notes I do try to address that
and keep those things in mind and I
always tell them you know anything that
I say is not set in stone it really is
up to you because you're the one who
created the project to make your
decision on what you think is best
I'm here to kind of give you guys an
idea of some of the things that could
possibly make it better or make it
stronger or make the character more
sympathetic so usually if I phrase
things in that way and if I look at it
that way they understand and I'm not
really like attacking them and I'm not
really so much as making a judgment call
it's really trying to give them another
way of looking at a problem and how they
might be able to solve it
you